including how he was quote pulled into
the crowd
away from my fellow officers beaten with
fists
metal objects stripped of my issued
badge
radio and ammunition magazine and
electrocuted numerous times with the
taser
in his officer in his letter officer
fanon writes
quote i've struggled daily with the
emotional anxiety
of having survived such a traumatic
event
but i also struggled with the anxiety of
hearing those who continued to downplay
the events of that day
and those who would ignore them all
together with their lack of
acknowledgement
his letter is a stark reminder the plain
facts of the events of that day
his attackers were not foreign
terrorists they were his fellow
americans
incited to insurrection and violence by
the then president of the united states
i ask unanimous consent that officer
fanon's may 5th
2021 letter b entered into direction
into the record and without objection
that is ordered
i want to say to all the officers of the
capitol police and every jurisdiction
who responded on january 6 and to those
who stand watch today we remember
and we honor your service i'd also like
to repeat something else i said at our
last hearing
to all officers ledge branch staff and
members
counseling and other assistance is
available to you
and you're encouraged to use those
resources at any time
and now i'd like to recognize our
ranking member mr davis from illinois
for his opening statement mr davis
thank you chairpersonal officer and
thank you to our witness
mr bolton for being here again i
appreciate the opportunity to discuss
your latest flash report
which is focused on counter surveillance
and threat assessment capabilities
within the united states capitol police
and highlighted the need for
improvements
as i noted at the last hearing you
testified at
i really appreciate your recommendations
and i agree with many of them
specifically i agree with the need to
increase the bandwidth in the department
to adequately handle the threat cases
toward members of congress
that continues to increase year after
year i continue to be extremely
concerned about the uscp's
limited intelligence gathering and
analysis capabilities we have the
intelligence about an attack
or threat against a member of congress
or against
the capital complex but do not have the
correct policies or people in place
to properly gather interpret and
operationalize that intel
and what's the point specifically mr
bolton's latest report
mentions uscp did not have detailed or
up-to-date guidance in place
for its counter surveillance and threat
assessment operations
i've raised this issue before and it's
been recommended by mr bolton
and general honore uh is
and it's the need to transform the uscp
into a protective force unless of a
traditional police department
mr bolton's latest report raises
concerns about the number of threats
against members and recommends greater
resources
be dedicated to the threat assessment
section
or tas as someone who's received
numerous threats one of which
resulted in a successful prosecution and
conviction
i would absolutely agree with that but
looking at the numbers provided in mr
bolton's report
i'm extremely concerned that while the
threats reported against members have
increased significantly
the number of arrests have stayed
relatively the same
as have the number of indictments that
seems to indicate to me
that there may be another issue at hand
that cannot be solved by simply
increasing
resources and will require a better
partnership
with the department of justice and other
executive branch law enforcement
partners
as well as state and local police and
prosecutors
i hope to get into i hope to get into
this more during my q a
but i'm very troubled by these
disproportionate numbers
related to issues with the tas i'd like
to ask permission
to enter into the record a recent
statement by the united states capitol
police
addressing mr bolton's third flash
report
with objection so ordered thank you
madam chair
in the statement released this past
friday uscp notes 107
increase in threats against members and
agrees with the recommendations by mr
bolton
and are working to implement many of
them but the department notes
that some of the most important
recommendations by mr bolton
require in addition to more resources
authorization or approval
from congressional stakeholders and to
me
that means the capitol police board this
is the point i've continued to make
throughout these hearings
while i'm happy to chat with mr bolton
again i'm disappointed the committee has
not yet publicly heard
from chief pittman or anyone else who
are responsible for implementing these
recommendations
also brings me to my next point and
that's the need for this committee to
hear
from the full capital police board as
i've mentioned several times before the
board has a ton of power
over the uscp therefore i think it's
imperative
and it looks like it's going to happen
that this committee is going to hear
from the entire board
just so everybody's aware according to
the congressional research service
the entire board hasn't appeared before
congressional oversight
in the house since 1945 that's 76 years
as mr bolton also noted in a previous
hearing there's little to no oversight
of the board
which makes the majority of security
decisions on capitol hill
i believe the oversight and
accountability is desperately needed
i think this committee could work
together to provide it
um i know the chair mentioned that she
intends to call a hearing
of the capitol police board but i'd like
the chair to engage in a
quick colloquy if
be happy to hear from the ranking member
well madam chair thank you again for
um showing the bipartisanship and
entering the request that many of us
have had
to uh from the capitol police board uh
could share a person
uh let the let the rest of the committee
know us
when you think that might happen i don't
have a date selected but we will
certainly work with minority
in the scheduling thank you madam chair
i appreciate the opportunity and the
time
and your willingness to work on this and
i'm hopeful we can continue this
dialogue
with another scheduled future hearings
regarding the security of this campus
protecting the capital should not be a
partisan issue and i believe working
together as the senate is doing
will ensure the reforms are actually
made and made
this congress with that i look forward
to discussing these issues
with mr bolton and i yield back
gentlemen yields back and without
objection other members opening
statements will need
be made a part of the record um
i want to welcome our witness back uh
inspector general bolton
you're no stranger to this committee and
we're grateful for your long career of
public service both with the
united states secret service and now
with the capitol police
as a reminder your entire written
statement will be made
part of the record and will remain open
for at least five additional
days for material to be submitted and
now we are pleased to hear from you
uh for about five minutes
thank you madam chair good afternoon and
thank you for this opportunity to pair
before you the committee of house
administration to discuss
our third flash report reviewing counter
surveillance
and threat assessment i'd like to extend
my appreciation to the committee
for holding these additional hearings
and for the continued support of my
office's review
i feel that it is at the utmost
importance to continue exploring and
reviewing the causes and failures
that led to the horrific events when the
capital was violently attacked
my goal is to provide each of you with a
better understanding of how these events
occurred
in relation to the preparation and
response of the department
other factors were involved other
entities are reviewing those aspects
outside of the capitol police
and i will discuss the non-law
enforcement sensitive findings detailed
in my third flash report
i will be happy to answer any law
enforcement sensitive questions in the
closed door setting
once again i would like to stress we did
not design
or intend our reports to cast blame on
any one individual
or group the office of special general
tendencies reports to be an independent
objective review
of the department's programs and
operation to better protect the capitol
complex members staff
visitors as well as the rank and file
officers
who have shown their commitment and
bravery each and every day
as our work continues my office sees
continuing areas in our findings
that capitol police needs addressing
those areas are intelligence
training operational planning and
cultural change
our third flash report reflects the
continuing need
for the department to focus on those
four areas of intelligence training
planning and cultural change
based on our ongoing work this flash
report is designed to communicate any
deficiencies with the department's
counter surveillance and threat
assessment operations
deficiencies include outdated or vague
guidance
failure to adequately report stop or
contact activities
a lack of dedicated counter surveillance
entity
insufficient resources for supporting
counter surveillance operations
and inadequate resources for supporting
its threat assessment
section the department did not
adequately provide detail and up-to-date
guidance
in place for its counter surveillance
and threat assessment operations
which could have led to unclear guidance
and accountability
additional additionally a lack of clear
and detailed communications procedures
could have increased inefficiencies with
processes
as well as led to critical counter
surveillance information
not being appropriately communicated
throughout the department
furthermore the department did not
actually document collect
analyze but their pd 76
stop or contact reports which may have
impeded its ability
to identify trends or patterns that
warrant further investigation or
dissemination
a standalone entity with a defined
mission dedicated to counter
surveillance activities
in support of protecting the
congressional community would improve
the department's ability to identify and
disrupt
individuals or groups intent on engaging
in illegal activity directed at the
congressional community or its
legislative process
the entity should be sufficiently
staffed to accomplish its mission
and have adequate resources include
dedicated analyst support
and a central desk to exploit
investigative disseminate and triage
information in real time
although the department has increased
the number of full-time employees within
threat assessment section the section
continues to experience manpower issues
in a previous report the ig found
threat assessment section caseload
suddenly increased from beginning
calendar year 2017
through the end of 2019.
department officials and tsa agents
stated that increased caseloads as well
as staffing levels
were some of the greatest challenges for
the threat assessment section
their assessment section did not have
investigative analysts
and agents perform tasks such as
database checks
that investigative analysts performed at
other agencies
we found allowing investigative analysts
to assume some responsibilities from
agents would help
the agents maintain a manageable
caseload for its staff
this is a third in a series of flash
reports the ig will produce as part of
an ongoing review of the events
surrounding to take over the united
states capital therefore we may still
perform additional in-depth work related
to those areas
during our review we anticipate that our
next flash report will focus on the
department's containment emergency
response team
and first responders unit
in conclusion the department is
comprised of extraordinary men and women
who are dedicated to protecting our
democracy putting their lives in harm's
way
in order for congress to exercise their
constitutional duties
in a safe and open manner it is our duty
to honor those officers who have given
their lives
but also ensuring the safety of all
those working and visiting the capitol
complex
by making hard changes within the
department
as we move forward the department is
taking steps in addressing our
recommendations from our previous two
flash reports
and i look forward to monitoring their
further progress
one additional thing based on
information developed from our previous
flash reports into
including additional concerns we have
changed the order in which we will be
conducting our
review of the department our june report
will focus on command and control to
include radio traffic
we anticipate that this flash report
will take 60 days as opposed to our
normal 30 days
to complete this based on the complexity
and the amount of materials to review as
well as
numerous interviews we plan on
conducting we also will be addressing
and reviewing the department's timeline
for its accuracy
thank you for the opportunity here
before you today and i'll be very happy
to answer any questions the committee
may have at this time
thank you uh mr bolton i appreciate your
report and your service
uh to our country now is the time when
members may
ask mr bolton questions for five minutes
i'll turn now to the
ranking member mr davis for his
questions
sorry madam chair uh
mr poland again i i want to turn to the
uh capitol police
capital police's threat assessment
intelligence gathering analysis
capabilities
prior to january 6 were you aware of the
capital police's deficiencies
in counter surveillance and threat
assessment operations
in regards to the threat assessment
section we did and we had uh
issued a report earlier recommending
that they increase their amount of nano
analysts and uh bringing our
uh some of their policy and procedures
up to date we had not looked at counter
surveillance since that was not a
standalone
entity uh that would not have fallen or
come under our radar okay
can you speak the department's current
intelligence gathering and analysis
capabilities
are those executed at a sufficient level
that you would have recommended in your
previous reports yet
when we conducted our previous report
they
as i stated their case load was very
high
but since that report their caseload has
basically exploded to even larger
numbers
uh so again we're recommending that they
increase their
uh level of analysts and agents to work
those cases because of the number of
threat cases
that have been generated on additional
resources now we also made a
recommendation
to utilize the fbi's behavioral analyst
unit
uh more frequently than what they did
when we spoke to them they indicate that
they could take on
much for or much more cases uh than what
we were previously providing them
great uh thank you for your responses
there mr bolton
ten years ago in tucson our former
colleague gabby giffords and 18 others
were shot by a gunman at an official
event tragically representative giffords
was severely wounded
and six people were killed since then
there's been an exponential increase in
the number of threats
made against members of congress however
there has been no corresponding increase
in the number of arrests
or indictments can you explain why
is this a resources for the department
it may not be so much a resource issue
for the department it may be more of a
resource
uh issue for uh department of justice
now we haven't looked at the
reasonings for um the
either the declaration explanation rate
or the reasons for the why the
u.s attorneys aren't taking the cases so
we haven't done any work in that field
so i wouldn't be able to give you a
definitive answer but there could be
many factors
as to why those cases the assessment
rise
in threat cases isn't coinciding with
the conviction rate
well speaking of some of those issues
you just mentioned
i know the department relies on federal
and state partners to protect members
outside of d.c how you know in your
recommendation have you made any
recommendations
about how the department can better
coordinate with partner agencies
to provide better security
in a previous report we did make a
recommendation to regionalize
the department in other words having
regional agents
assigned to sections of the country that
way they could
form more partnerships with our local
and state partners and with the united
states attorney's office
within that district so we have made the
previous recognition i believe the
department has
acted on that um they will also they are
opening up two regional offices one in
san francisco
and i believe one in miami so they are
taking a recommendation that they will
be regionalizing
and trying to get their folks out uh
into the field
in that way form better partnerships and
relationships
which could help us in getting our
prosecution numbers up
well i really appreciate that but coming
from the midwest that doesn't
necessarily look like
a regional approach to me being in san
francisco and miami
because as you know my colleagues and i
were attacked on a baseball field only a
few years ago
even more recently a man was charged and
prosecuted
and convicted for threatening to kill me
so i know firsthand that these threats
are real
and that the people making these threats
intend to act on them
i do believe that a truly more a more
aggressive enforcement stance
more arrests and more prosecutions of
those who make violent threats
and intend to carry them out would be a
very strong deterrent
what can the department do to encourage
federal state and local law enforcement
prosecutors to take a more aggressive
stance do you need to widen this
this this regional net because clearly
i'm not i don't know anybody who's going
to be satisfied
with the regional approach of offices
going to san francisco and miami
well let me clarify one thing and i
didn't fail i failed to mention
is that this is the first of um
i think the department was thinking at
least five field offices
initially this is the first of those so
there'll be additional
uh field offices there's discussion of
chicago
um i believe in texas some so there are
additional field offices that
these are just the first two that
they're they're putting out so there
i know the department was in discussion
in having additional field
offices out there so they would be able
to cover the midwest and
those areas um a lot of times in my
experience
with when i was with the service is when
you actually get out and meet
the united states attorney all
attorney's office the ausa
and you form a friendship and a bond and
that you
you have a much better chance of getting
your case it's just having
it's that interaction uh so by the
department getting out more
in meeting and greeting the united
states attorney's office
and their folks i think we'll have
better success
in getting our cases prosecuted along
with
strengthening our current ties with the
fbi and other federal and local law
enforcement agencies
i couldn't agree more mr bolton my time
is up and i certainly hope that the
leaders of the capitol police and
uh the leaders in congress uh realize
the regional approach means a regional
approach and look forward to working
with you on
yield back gentlemen yields back uh the
gentleman
from maryland mr raskin is recognized
thank you very much madam chair for
calling this crucial hearing
mr bolton there's a 30 to one
officer to analyst ratio within the
threat assessment
section and that's actually not just a
ratio those are the actual numbers if
i'm reading it correctly 30 officers
to one analyst how does that ratio
compare to other federal law enforcement
agencies do we need more analysts
and tell us why the work of analysts is
important
thank you sir uh it's not even close to
uh your other federal agencies the 30 to
one
ratio uh what are our
experience not not only mine with the
secret service but also
the counterpart with the fbi generally
it's like either five to two
five to one ratio is more the optimum
the analyst can take a lot of the burden
off of your
your investigator agents officers and
conducting a lot of the checks
background checks and doing a lot of the
legwork initially
to form up a package to provide to the
special agents to review and to continue
on whether or not they need additional
steps
so they can carry a lot of the burden
initially and get a lot of the work
quicker
done within hours as opposed to days
so those analysts are very important as
long as they're well trained
with the knowledge and the ability and
have this skills
they can take a lot of that burden and
they can turn these cases over
quicker and more efficiently and making
sure we don't
miss any steps or we don't miss any
particular information that's very
important
um your report says that the
intelligence
operations section which is responsible
for counter surveillance
had only 13 officers deployed on january
6
to provide actual time intelligence
to the department does the department
have more than 13 counter surveillance
officers or is that it
and if there were more why weren't they
deployed on the six
how many are there i think i believe
that number is correct sir
um the problem we saw with counter
surveillance
is it's not a standalone entity so
when we had the pipe bombs three of the
teams went to those pipe bombs and
because they're doing double duty they
started conducting an investigation
that left one team to cover the capital
complex
so in other words if those pipe bombs
were intended to be a diversion
plane was speaking it worked yes sir so
how many officers were diverted to the
pipe bombs at the dnc in the rnc
six it would have been six so it'd be
three teams two teams usually run with
two
so there were only seven officers left
for the the rest of the siege of the
capital basically
oh two two so there were four teams
initially so
it would have been just two there and
the other six so eight
would have been total okay now
like i said they do double duty as well
as
let me ask you this um
how much were uh our
people in threat assessment caught
unaware
just by the sheer magnitude and ferocity
of
the violent attack on the capitol
um i know that the department of
homeland security had identified
domestic violent extremism violent white
supremacy as the number one terror
threat
uh in the country but were they just
overwhelmed and
stunned at the complexity and magnitude
of the attack
thank you sir i would i would venture to
say yes and that
that was the problem because what we
pointed out
by lack of having adequate policies and
procedures
and truly defined roles all this
information that was coming
in to the department it didn't go
anywhere they weren't able to triage it
uh that's why we were we mentioned like
a duty desk
that would receive and then disseminate
that information
vet it out and get it out to the either
the commanders in the field or even down
to the front line officers
so you're saying the information was
flowing in but because there was only
one analyst there was no way really to
synthesize it interpret it and then
parlay it into an effective response
that would be a correct assessment yes
sir okay
um let's see um do you
think that the threat assessment threat
assessment section today
can produce standardized intelligence
reports
that can actually be implemented and
used
by the uh force
uh well i know that the department is
working on that as we speak
in fact they have responded to my first
written response a department provided
my office on april 30th the written
response for the first series of
uh recommendations from the flashport
they are currently working on
uh putting together their policies and
procedures and defining the roles and
responsibilities for those of
those folks so they are moving forward
that they have requested um
closure on two of the recommendations in
the first report we're analyzing that
and requesting additional documents to
see if we can able to close those
recommendations but
the our department is moving forward and
we're and after progress
or the process is uh ongoing thank you
are you back madam chair
thank you the gentleman's time has
expired mr style is now recognized thank
you madam chair
and inspector general bolton thank you
for being with us
uh once again uh both your flash reports
and the honorary
uh honorary report recommended that
capitol police
shift from being a police force to a
protective force
can you provide an example of protective
forces that you have in mind
it would be something somewhere along
the lines of say the secret service
where they have the uniform division
they have
uh the ability to reach out and
for training intelligence where it's a
full-fledged
uh counter surveillance that all the
other elements are
within that and so then building on that
do you think that type of change is
possible with the with the capitol
police
and and how should the capitol police
begin to make this shift
i certainly believe the capitol police
is more than capable of making that
shift
uh part of that would be having the
infrastructure and i spoke with this on
the previous hearings even if we hire
a thousand officers we were magically
able to
produce them it really doesn't if we
don't have the infrastructure
training if we're not training the
officers not just the initial training
the basic but the continuous educational
training and
and gear our training towards a
protective model
as opposed to a police department then
we're not going to accomplish our goals
we need to be thinking long term and how
to best
uh provide the infrastructure for these
officers
to be properly trained and continuously
trained and on that but develop
new uh or having the ability to
see um new and developing uh
threats and tactics that they would need
to be
to employ and and to build on the
training aspect it's my understanding
that
only about 12 out of 28 capital police
instruct
capital police instructors are certified
is that correct
that is correct sir as far as i know and
then do you believe that the
the best training structure would be to
centralize this training
or how else do you believe that this
would work
the only way uh i believe and this is
speaking from
uh being at the office of training with
the secret service as well as my
assistant inspector general for
investigations who did a stun
uh in raleigh training center if it's
not centralized it's
it's doomed to fail it has to be
centralized at the office of training
training services
has to be there conducting all training
from the highest level
down to the lowest and how do you think
that this type of a shift would be
received
by the men and women that are in service
currently at the capitol police
from the other previous hearings that
i've attended and i've heard uh
certainly the union has been a voice of
needing
wanting more training so i would imagine
that the rank-and-file would welcome us
yeah and to sort of to build on this if
we move forward with uh with that
recommendation the capitol police begins
to make this shift
what measurements of success should we
be
tracking and looking at
that's kind of a hard difficult the
measure of success
is going to be how our officers respond
to incidents
okay and so so so to build on this
conversation then with the capitol
police if we were to begin this change
today
um which changes do you think would
require uh board approval or which could
just begin to be implemented
uh under the current structure
i think it's going to be more of a
question of
funds having the available funds to
start making that change
i don't believe that they would need uh
capitol police board approval
to ramp up and start conducting with the
training out in cheltenham
doing what would be needed to enhance
our training and to make it centralized
uh it would certainly just be more
question of funds so as you look at
police reform generally
um not just inside uh the capitol police
but are you
do you believe that's generally it's a
it's a funding issue
are there other aspects such as cultural
shifts or board
uh adjustments as well that would be
needed
well i can only speak on as far as with
the campbell police serve programs and
operations it's it's
it's going to be a fundamental shift in
uh cultural
change as i spoke before and additional
funds and it's going to
when i speak cultural change is where
you are changing the way
we conduct our own training in the
thought process there
okay um one of the the recent flashports
uh
included information regarding the
capitol police's lack of consistency in
reviewing its standard operating
procedures
uh and internal policies and we talked
about this last time
uh is the inspector general have you
been experiencing
additional difficulties on obtaining
information regarding internal policies
uh we have not had any difficulty in
obtaining the policies or any
materials or documents that we've
requested from the department they've
been
very uh helpful and timely in producing
any documents we've requested
okay so how receptive do you believe
that capitol police have been
to your past recommendations
for the most part i would say they've
been very receptive uh to our uh
recommendations
okay i i appreciate your time today i'm
sensitive to the clock here and
uh with that madam chair i'll yield back
general yields back uh mr aguilar is now
recognized
thank you madam chair and uh inspector
general bolton thanks for being here
um if i could just pull at the thread
that mr style
um started or ended his his questions
with
because during the 2019
uh capitol police oversight hearing
before this committee you testified that
one of
the top management challenges facing the
department was a lack of
strong integrated internal control
systems in other words a lack of
clear updated and standardized policies
and procedures
you said at the time that over the years
the department had tended to resolve
individual issues rather than
strengthening the underlying
systemically weak controls causing the
issues
one of your primary findings in this
report is that the department still has
vague outdated policies so i understand
that they're forthcoming to give you
these policies but
how did these how did the policy
deficiencies themselves
adversely affect the department's threat
assessment section and intelligence
operations section
uh prior to and on january 6th
thank you sir the problem when you have
either outdated policies or
vague policies it doesn't provide the
direction
that the officers or where their
assignment is and what's expected of
them
how you're going to hold them
accountable in other words if you're not
telling them that they need to produce
an example a weekly report and provide
it to their commanding officer
if it doesn't specify what's supposed to
be in the report if you just send
an email a one line email well that's
going to satisfy that particular policy
but is it useful is it going to be
something that they can actually act
upon
the information so you really need to be
specify
what information either the task force
agents or the threat assessment section
and what report
and what should be in in that report if
you're not specifying that then
what's the point of you if you're just
sending a one sentence say yeah
i worked eight hours every day last week
there's no value in that kind of report
who within the department is responsible
to update those
it's really incumbent upon whoever
is overall in charge of let's say for
protected services
that would be the deputy chief's uh
responsibility to make sure all the
policies and procedures are at least up
to date
uh they should be doing a review and
making sure that their policies like we
found
policies are referencing blackberries we
haven't used blackberries in years
so whenever there's a change you have to
update your policies
how frequently should the department
update these policies and procedures
can't wouldn't be able to give them them
a specific timeline or time frame but
they should
again that would be a policy and
procedure they should have in place
of periodically reviewing their
particular policies and procedures in
other words deputy chief should have a
like particular system every two years
i'm going to sign somebody to review our
policy make sure they're
up to date so that they they need to
actually take it upon themselves to
provide a repeatable business practice
if if i could list you some specific
investigations division policies and
procedures
with you and ask and ask these questions
prior to january 6th
when was the investigations division
protective intelligence team
responsibilities standard operating
procedures updated
are you talking about dpd policy
procedures
didn't play protective or some of you
uh i had to stop and think um i know we
did
recently a uh a report
a review of the entire protective
division i believe that was about maybe
a year ago
two years ago yeah show up
we show a march uh what we show a march
of 2009
date uh is is potentially that last
update
what about the protective intelligence
team assignments
um as well uh we did recently one for
like the task force we did
and have them update their policies and
procedures for the task force agents
um which that was pretty recent uh i
believe
uh probably a little over a year ago
what
what about something like the suspicious
activity trend analysis
no we have not done any work in that
field okay
so there's there's still plenty of work
to do i guess is my is my main point
when it comes to
to updating these policies you know and
procedures
one last uh question you know you've
talked a little bit about
funding um in answer to a prior question
the house committee on appropriations is
considering a security supplemental
looking at the issues that you raised in
these flash reports
what would be your top line
recommendations to the committee
for funding priorities
well that's a dangerous question sir
i would say um the number one priority
would be training uh again like i spoke
if you if you don't have the
infrastructure
you're not gonna have i can get the
results you want so training would be
the number
one priority thank you thank you yield
back madam chair
gentlemen yields back the gentleman from
north carolina mr butterfield
is now recognized thank you very much
madam chair for accommodating my
schedule it's been a very hectic day but
thank you and thank you
to your staff for for working through my
technical problems
uh mr bolton thank you again for your
testimony today you've been very
cooperative with the committee
and we thank you very much uh mr bolton
prior to january 6 this committee
expressed
your office great concern about the
growing number of threats to members of
congress
as a result in september of 2020 at the
request of the committee you issued a
report
entitled assessment of the u.s capitol
police threat assessment
section i think you may recognize that
my question is did the september 2020
report
reveal specific deficiencies with threat
assessments
most notably what we we discovered was
the
uh the manpower issue with the analysts
that that was
basically what came out of that report
was that
uh because of the rise and threats that
they didn't have enough manpower which
they started addressing
uh back then but due to the fact that um
threats have exponentially increased
even beyond what it was back in
september 2020
again we're recommending additional
analysts uh
to be able to handle that kind of
caseload
but aside from analysts did you make any
other recommendations
yes sir we did make uh several other
recommendations only couple
previous ones uh
we recommended that they ensure
documentation
for their training and staff which they
have done
they have started putting in because we
did recognize or see that
some of their training records were
either incomplete or missing
we did recommend also that that back
then was the regional approach for
managing threats against which they have
now start uh gotten like i said to two
field officers um
looking they uh
so that was the of the recommendations
um
are you satisfied with the progress
they're making on these recommendations
as a date those yes sir i am uh
well as i say we are evaluating delay
the
response by the department to our first
flash report
um so we are evaluating that but they
i do i am encouraged by their um
movement movement into getting these
recommendations completed
all right when you discuss
threat assessment section statistics
within your report you make a
distinction
between threat cases and direction of
interest cases
the department defines the direction of
interest
as quote information received by the
uscpd from any source
where a subject expresses an unusual
interest in
any personal property under the police
jurisdiction in the quote
so my question is this is an extremely
vague and broad definition what was the
department able to provide
was the department able to provide
additional details on
specificities of institutions
uh well sir um
last part of your question was kind of
broken up but i think what you're asking
for is
how they classify like a direction of
interest or a
actual threat case well that goes into
their process um
an individual it could be uh just
showing an unusual or
an interest in a particular member of
congress that doesn't quite rise
to an actual threat in other words
individuals not actually
expressing a viable threat against a
member of congress or
to to the capital complex but they're
showing an unusual
interest now that individual you know
would be monitored or
could be uh certainly put into the
system to keep an eye on
or what have you and they do keep those
definitions and that's nothing new
uh certainly a lot of the other
protective agencies they use similar
language to
that uh that way uh they if they keep it
broad
that way they have an understanding that
an individual can move from one
from a direction of interest to an
actual threat case
all right well thank you madam chair
i yield back very much
the gentlelady from pennsylvania is
recognized
thank you madam chair um well as
as detailed in this and our previous
flash reports
um usdp appears to
lack the proper procedures and
intelligence protocols to proactively
and effectively
deal with threats to the capital and
those deficiencies were on full display
january
6. um when it appears that uscp's
counter surveillance measures
failed to identify and properly warn of
the variety of threats
within and around the complex um
you've made a number of recommendations
with regard to counter surveillance
but many of them seem very focused on
in-person kind of old-fashioned
investigative
legwork referencing agents who are
working in person
on foot on bicycle or in vehicles
um but the origins of january 6 were
digital
um or virtual they began really with a
twitter invitation from the former
president for his supporters to
come quote uh for a
big protest in dc january 6 be there
will be wild
end quote um and so
many of us saw you know the activity the
organization
uh that that resulted from that
invitation
so do any of your recommendations
address what the uscp should do to
address
whether individuals domestic terrorists
extremists who
who organize online
well not in this particular report in
our previous reports when we were
talking about
uh intelligence um where we're basically
telling they need to become a bureau
level that
would be able to get down
more into the weeds so to speak uh for
that digital
um thing now this report dealt with the
council surveillance which basically is
your your folks on the ground to give
you real-time information
okay so so with respect to those counter
surveillance officers
um your report noted that they didn't
have a formalized process to pass on
information they collected
nor a formalized policy on how that
information
makes its way to decision makers how did
that deficiency hamper the department's
efforts to obtain real-time intelligence
on january 6.
well that goes the very thing that if if
they're out
the officers and agents are out there on
the ground
providing this real-time intelligence
real-time information
and it's getting back to the folks
threat assessment but if it goes no
further if it's not analyzed or acted
upon
then it's worthless information it's
like why do you even have that
information
if it's not acted upon that's going to
inhibit
real time it's it's think of it as as
the game is going on
and you're getting that real-time
information and down to the team to be
able
to take move pieces around that's where
it's going to be
critical that you have that real-time
information
did the intelligence operations section
have a plan of action
for deployment of their officers on
january 6 and if so was it provided to
your office
uh no ma'am they really the the only
plan of action that we've ever come
across was that initial
in our first flash report the cdu
operational plan which they did mention
that
there would be uh counter surveillance
units but there was no actual
plan for the counter surveillance units
of what
they were going to do one of the key
findings in your flash report is that
department officers failed to adequately
report
stop or contact activities using the
stopper contact report
which i guess that's a pd 76 report in
the department
under what circumstances should a
stopper contact report be
produced anytime you
if you notice an individual that's not
acting uh in accordance with the normal
day-to-day or what they should be uh you
need to be reporting any suspicious
activity
uh so that they could either analyze it
get the person on camera what have you
do more investigative work why is this
individual acting the way they are
those those reports are vital and
important to get it to the command staff
get it to the folks here to analyze it
investigate it
so that information is either passed
down as a
a lookout watch out for this individual
so the others for
for your foot soldiers your your basic
rank and file officers are standing
posed
they get that information to be on the
lookout for this particular individual
or group
that may pose a danger and that then you
can then connect accordingly
whether realignment of your forces or
what have you
um can you tell us am i correct that
only four
stop and contact reports were completed
on january 6 and how many should have
been
that i'm not sure about how many but
you're correct they're four i found it
was what 2 18
a.m and the other i thought it was three
it could be i thought it was just a
three uh
um and they were like six and yeah like
six nineteen six twenty
um and maybe i'll tell you that a little
more because when our
june flash report it's going to cover
radio traffic
and just by a little bit that we have
already reviewed
there should have been many more i can't
give you a number right now but
hopefully after our june report i'll be
able to tell you a little bit better how
many there should have been
thank you i see my time has expired so i
yield that
the gentlelady from new mexico is
recognized
thank you madam chairman um and thank
you inspector general
bolton for coming again uh to share your
offices find ear
finding and recommendations you know
just at the outset inspector general
you know i i'm going to be asking
questions about
morale as well as capacity you know and
i am very disturbed by
the violence that you know officer fanon
has described in his open letter to
congress
and the concern that some in congress
continue to downplay the significance of
the insurrection
which was based on a lie about who won
the election
um you know that letter for nunn's
letter indicates that
those that seek to ignore the role of
president trump
and his allies that the role they played
in that insurrection
does impact the morale of the u.s
capitol police
and those that came to their end her aid
on january 6
right so what we're doing today is the
way i see it is focusing on the aspects
that can
be controlled by the department and the
role that those of us in congress can
play
to strengthen the department's
capabilities uh to protect the capital
and to protect themselves right
i am we have a saying here in new mexico
it's out and
everywhere right i want our officers to
know they're part of an organization
that's effective
and that supports them in other words
the officers need to know that
we have their backs right that we're
going to support them so i want to talk
about about your specific recommendation
to create an
independent entity for counter
surveillance um
so in your thoughts what must the
department do to attract and retain
talent in the counter surveillance
section you mentioned
a bit about the importance of additional
training in response to representative
aguilar's questions
but can you elaborate is it increased
wages better training
is it a better overall structure you
know and how will this
in your opinion how will all of this
affect the morale of the department
thank you ma'am um i doubt that they
would need
any kind of incentives for counter
surveillance that it alone is probably
this is very desirable uh assignment as
opposed to right now
uh your civil disturbance unit which
quite frankly i don't think you know a
lot of people are gonna line up for
uh to volunteer for that that and alone
if you make that a separate entity
you're going to have folks
i believe uh volunteering left and right
your problem is going to be make getting
them
out of the count of surveillance because
they'll want to stay there probably
for a very long time that would
you know just by making it a standalone
entity is going to provide
the officers a sense of understanding
what their duties are
there's nothing worse than when you're
standing post and i can speak from
experience when you do not
know what your assignment is or what you
can and cannot do
that's demoralized when you know exactly
what your roles are what your
responsibility is
you're going to take pride in that and
you're going to execute
those roles and responsibilities when
you're left on your own
you feel down you you're
you're not quite sure what you're doing
and it's going to affect your morale
so uh this answers a bit my second
question i wanted to find follow-up to
determine whether you thought
we'd be it'd be best to hire uh within
the department and train for that or
whether uh
we'd be looking for external candidates
and do you have some thoughts on that
your answer to that indicated that
there would be a lot of hiring from
within
uh for like counter surveillance oh yes
you would there definitely would be
hiring from within we have
uh i believe the the officers we have
the talent here
um we just need to give them the right
direction and they're going to exceed
that's all we have to do is provide them
the training
uh the right equipment and focus
and they are going to exceed our
expectations great
and with regards to what authority is
now can the department of chief
hire qualified individuals for this role
now
or do we need to provide additional
legislative authority
as far as the counter surveillance
entity would not
require a legislative fix um and
certainly if
if it required a change in the org chart
if you're going to designate it as a
thing that my understanding would
require
congressional approval okay and so
we'll look at that and then uh going to
the idea of the
uh the importance of more investigative
analysts within the threat assessment
section
so what are some of the best practices
that you think the department should
follow
with regards to augmenting the threat
assessment section
with the investigative analysts
well certainly trying to get down to
five to two would be
a huge undertaking
it i think they look to other agencies
and how
and uh they go about hiring just the
necessary skills
and abilities for those uh analysts and
keeping them trained so again
it goes back to training if we're not
continuously training for new
uh different uh developing
uh threats i think then we're missing
out
so there's always something that is new
and uh
emerging that they have to be staying on
top of it so it really goes back to
training
and but there's plenty of folks out
there we can pluck off the street
uh to get us started into that thing
because they're basically they're
civilian
staff so it's a lot easier to hire
civilian than it is
for law enforcement and having to send
them down to fletchy
federal law enforcement training center
or cheltenham thank you mr bolton my
time has expired and
it sounds like training and stability
are key i yield back
uh made more acute i mean no one
doubts the officers went
on the line to protect us and they went
without adequate equipment
or instructions and from the testimony
we got from one
opr um
responded anyhow it was confusing what
they were looking for
uh and according to what this officer at
least recalled
according to his sworn testimony
sometimes you only can
can assimilate what you see
when you have an open mind and if
it was believed that really what was
facing us was a fight between pro and
anti-trump demonstrators
and other information coming in maybe
didn't get
the kind of serious attention that it
needed
i was looking at the the timeline that
that the department provided uh you the
timeline of events
uh preceding january 6th and on that day
which you included in the report now
according to the department's timeline
at 10
59 a.m this is a quote approximately
200 proud boys gather near garfield
circle
and move toward senate egg end quote now
in addition to being a far-right
extremist
organization that the southern poverty
law center
describes as a hate group the proud boys
are the group that former president
trump told to quote
stand back and stand by end quote during
a nationally televised
presidential debate now did the
department
uh assign counter-surveillance teams
to monitor the 200 proud boys near
garfield circle that were moving towards
the senate egg because
there's no other references to the proud
boys in the department's
timeline and according to the
department's timeline less than a half
an hour later
at 11 24 am quote
uscp personnel monitors three to four
counter demonstrators setting up props
on third street and pennsylvania
southeast
now why did the department decide to
monitor
the three to four counter demonstrators
but apparently according to this
timeline not to monitor uh the proud
boys
uh there's there's no other reference to
the proud boys in the department's
timeline
what happened to these 200 proud boys
over the course
of the day the day uh on january 6 and
who is responsible for deploying
department personnel to monitor
the three counter three or four counter
demonstrators but
apparently not the 200 proud boys
thank you ma'am um that is part of
the reason why the very questions that
you just raised
um why we moved our command and control
and radio traffic to june as opposed we
were planning on doing that later in the
summer
as we were doing our previous things and
we were looking also looking at the
timeline
we're calling into question the accuracy
first of the timeline
we had a lot of questions ourselves uh
hence why we are
we have moved our command and control uh
review
uh to june um we anticipate like i
previously stated 60 days to complete
that
i'm hoping that we will be able to
provide you exact answers
after that report but we certainly we
have the same kind of concerns
uh hence what command and control up
okay okay i as mr aguilar mentioned we
had a hearing
on the um uh
with the capitol police some time ago
and in 2018 i asked then chief
uh berndarossa a question that never
really got answered
which was a concern about a scenario
where a diversion is used to drain law
enforcement from their primary
mission and i asked about the protocols
that were in place
to address that scenario and there were
instances where that occurred subsequent
to that hearing where i
privately have asked the police
chief and subsequent chiefs about this
issue and never really got
an adequate answer can you tell me how
if at
all um you know we all know that there
was
pipe bombs uh planted at both the
republican and democratic headquarters
and troops were diverted officers were
diverted to deal with that
um leaving the capital
less protected how if at all would
the department's actions with respect to
pipe bombs or other diversions
be different if the department were a
protective agency
as opposed to a more traditional law
enforcement agency
i think thank you ma'am i think it goes
to a mindset where
invariably when there's an incident
police officer swarm
when you're in a protective mode you
have an area of responsibility you have
defined
areas where you can and cannot go and
respond
that scenario then it would have been uh
set up a perimeter
and call an mpd a metropolitan police
department and the fbi
to handle the investigative work we go
back to a protective mode
so the only thing we'd be doing is
coordinating off keeping civilians away
from the area
but not diverting our forces uh
to that area we call them metropolitan
once they arrive in the fbi they secure
the scene
we go back to our duties our other
duties
so we don't conduct that investigative
work there allow them to do it
i thank you answer and i think that
we've learned a lot today from hearing
from you inspector general and we're
looking forward to the next report which
i think will be very enlightening
um and we'll have additional questions
for you
at that time as
i mentioned earlier members may have
additional questions for
you and if so we will send them to you
in writing
and request that you respond to them and
the hearing record will be open
for a bit for those responses
i want to thank you again for being here
we'll see you again i guess next month
and
i want to remind the members of the
committee
that we'll hear from the inspector
general of the architect of the capitol
uh a day after tomorrow so i look
forward to seeing all of you
then and without objection uh the
committee on house administration
will now be adjourned
you